さあみんな
ツイッターの時間だ
はじめは何歳までお年玉をもらっていましたか
ええとね多分ね大学卒業するまでかな学生中はもらってた気がします
みんなも親戚の人にお金を集ろうね
〔くしゃみ〕こんにちははじめ社長です
みなさん宝くじ買いましたか？
アハまさか買ってない？アハハ
宝くじ当たる確立は非常に低いんですけどもみなさん買わないと
そもそもあたらないんですよ
宝くじ皆さんどうせ当たんねー当たんねー
どうせ当たんない当たんないなんで買うのバッカじゃないの
〔机をたたく音〕買わないと当たらないからだよー
どんなに低い確率でも
必ず宝くじを買わないと
当たる人たちの中にすら入れないということはあのー買ってない皆さんはもうだめです
ただ僕はもう買ってあるんで
当たる当たらないにしろ
買うことに意味があると思っています
買わないと当たる可能性がゼロになってしまうので
俺は何を言いたいんだろう
よくわかんないですけども僕今回宝くじを買いました
それもすごいことにですね静岡にすげー店があってな見てくださいこれ
静岡駅前の店なんですけども
2015年7億円2016年も7億円おかげさまで2年連続1等大当たり
いただいた
これは完全にいただいた2年連続1等
2015年2016年７億円出ているお店です
ちゃんと宝くじ買ったのすごい久しぶりなんですよねえっと二万円分宝くじ買いました
マジでマジで当たっててて当たってたらどうしよう
７億円当たったらもう俺良くなっちゃうよー多分
1等が７億円1等の前後賞が1.5億円1等組違い賞が30万円
2等1000万円3等100万円
4等10万円5等1万円
6等3000円7等300円よーしじゃあちょっと見ていきますか
あっ300円だ！300円300円
バラで3枚買ったら一枚300円でした
アド
こっからはバラを開けてゆく
もうね700万円でいいからほしい
違う
300円！ようやく600円手に入れました
なんとも言えねー気分だ
くーダメかーくそー今のところ600円です
どんどん見ていきましょう
300円！
さぁ来い！
〔驚き〕違う300円
ああいい感じ
でもこれで
1200円分ですね　ヤべーー
元取れねーー
違う　ほい！
こっからが本番です見ていきます
ダメじゃーん
はっ！はっ！
3000円だ！3000円！3000円！3000円3000円3000円
57だと
3000円みたいです
やったやったやったー、3000円だやった
3000円か...せめて10万ほしい
せめて10万欲しいよ　いやなんか当たりそうで当たんねーなー
え、まってこれまって184うわっ
三桁合ってるけど三桁ちがうなー
くっそーおしい　あーなんだよもう　次いきます
ラストいきます　お願いお願いホント１億でいいから　一億でいいから当たって
楽して生きたい...！
終わった...終わった　ああもうダメだ　クッソー
なんでーなんでxorekrd－ー(泣)
3000円が1本　300円が7本で
5100円！
まって足攣(つ)った足攣ったまって足攣った足攣った
という動画で終わろうと思ったんですけども
こんなつまんない動画で俺は終らないぜ！　下にも後輩が二人いるんですけども逆に適当なやつを
この年末ジャンボのこの適当な　136組
108184番逆にこの年末ジャンボ宝クジの
当たり表みたいなやつを自分で作って
あたかも1等がこれだったような状況を作れば
みんなは俺が1等7億円当たったんじゃねーかと思い込む作戦やってみようと思います
あぁ完璧だよ完璧すぎる完成しました
完全に1位が僕の宝くじになっております
というわけで早速後輩二人に
僕があたかも7億当たったかのように振舞ってみます　それでは、スタート
はっ
うっぇーー
わぁーー！わっはっわっ
ねぇちょっと
またまた　　　またまた
えっ
えっ　まって　ヤバくない！？　うそでしょ！？
136... 10..えっヤバっえっヤバいヤバいヤバいえっえっえっ
えっ7億じゃん　えっヤバ！？
えっ　はっ？ヤバいうそでしょ！？結構ヤバくない？
合ってるよね？マジあってるよね？36の1081
あっちょっヤベー　えっヤバいヤバい意味わからない
えっうそでしょ！？
は！？えっ！？
ていうドッキリなんだけどね
なんだよーー
あははは
ははは
シンプルにヤバって思った
今日いつもよりドタバタがすごいから
引っかかったなーマジで